another young black man is dead in the
u.s. at the hands of police
now Atlanta Georgia's police chief has
resigned as a result and the mayor has
called for the officer involved to be
fired area residents have converged on
the scene of the incident to protest the
Friday night shooting death of 27 year
old Rashard Brooks Atlanta Police say he
was asleep in his car blocking a
fast-food drive-through lane he said to
have resisted arrest
after failing a sobriety test now
security footage then shows Brooks
running away with the officers stun gun
and possibly pointing it back at them
when police opened fire and killed him
with an estimated three shots the
incident comes amid widespread protests
over police brutality and systematic
racism around the world a day of street
protests have been keeping the focus on
just that institutional racism grief and
frustration sparked by the death of
George Floyd a black man who died under
the knee of a white police officer in
the u.s. city of Minneapolis in May was
met by far-right groups how to protect
monuments that they see as part of their
national identity police had warned
everyone to stay home
the threat of spreading the corona virus
was too great but in the air at
Trafalgar Square smoke bombs and tear
gas bottles and rocks were the main
concern as police tried to keep anti
racism protests separated from counter
protests nearly everyone breaching
pandemic risk measures peaceful or not
at one of the main train stations black
lives matter marches were right in the
face of police on this square police
gave ground to right-wing activists at
one point but took it back a little
later
on this Boulevard though they conceded
the space the Prime Minister called it
racist thuggery tweeting that these
marches and protests have been subverted
by violence and breach current
guidelines current pandemic guidelines
that his interior minister said have to
be followed but I think we should all be
very mindful of the fact that these
gatherings will spread this disease and
put people's health at risk and that is
simply not acceptable and we want to
prevent that in Paris a massive
anti-police brutality march set
coronavirus distancing concerns aside
but authorities allowed the stationary
demonstration until protesters tried to
move
that's when teargas rained down
furthering the distance between those
protesting police and the police
themselves one bit of counter protest
here of far-right sign claiming anti
racism protesters are anti white a sort
of tug of racial war over the sign
ensued as fists were raised the sign was
eventually torn down